I love this show so much short uh season
three of Shira oh my god okay yeah if
you liked this show I can't imagine that
you wouldn't enjoy this season it's good
stuff I it was exactly what I wanted it
to be broadly speaking coming off of the
second season because I mentioned in my
review of season two that that season
was much more self contained episodes it
didn't quite have the serialized feel of
the first season had for the most part
and I didn't have a problem with that in
season two but I did say at the time
that I didn't want that to become the
new norm I wanted to see in you know
because those individual episodes gave
us closer looks at some of the
characters which I appreciated but I
wanted to see a return to a more overall
the the story it overall is going
somewhere sort of feel to it and that's
exactly what the season is this is a
very surreal I season this is basically
a single story told in six episodes so
it's a continuous story broken into
parts rather than a bunch of little
individual stories like the previous
season one I can see where some people
might find it jarring that the show
seems to be going back and forth in
terms of how it does it but for me I
this this is what I wanted I you know I
got to know individual characters and
settings and relationships a bit better
last time because of the episodic nature
but this time like I wanted the story to
just Thunder forward and it does and we
do still get some really good character
beets and some interesting insights
along the way as well I will try to
avoid spoilers no scratch that
I will not avoid spoilers I liked it
a lot it's only six episodes they're
like 20-some odd minutes apiece it's
like two and a half hours go watch it
then come back crying out loud
okay so boy now that now that I open it
up to talk spoilers I I feel lost where
do I start
well okay so Katra let's start with
Katra they pushed her hard they pushed
her to the edge and if it hadn't been so
carefully balanced in terms of
justifying explaining why she felt that
this was what she wanted to do then it
could have it could have been very
hollow could have been very well you
just need someone to make the the stupid
over arch evil decisions I guess they
decided it's gonna be her it could have
been that but it's not because it the
show does a really good job and the both
the visual physical perform I say
physical it's drawn but you know the the
physicality of the character and the
vocal performance do a lot to sell and
make me buy that she is the kind of
person that has poured so would like all
of her failings all of her fears all of
her hate at external forces and she has
poured that so heavily into them and is
so determined to hate these people
partly shadowy but mostly adora that and
she is committed to that so fully I buy
that it's not about catch her winning
all she wants to do is make sure that
adora doesn't win and that doesn't even
necessarily mean that a door is even up
against Katra so this isn't even a
direct competition a doors trying to do
stuff that doesn't even have to involve
capture but Katra does not want her to
win at whatever it is that is the level
of hate that she has for her and they
sell that because they built it over
three seasons for her to be at this
level of hatred for her that I buy it
that she
would let the world fall apart if Edoras
goal was to stop that happening she
would ensure that it did just so she
could say that adora lost not even that
she beat her but just that adora didn't
get something she wanted and they do a
really good job of making her feel very
legit to somebody with a lot of damage
and a lot of unhealthy abusive
relationships in their past that is kind
of that element kind of hit me when
she's looking at shadow Weaver
you know paired with adora and with
glimmer and bow and you know obviously
we can't trust shot a weaver we know
that but it's a desperate situation but
Katra sees that and says I am the mess
that I am because you knowingly ruined
me and now you get to be the good guy oh
no no no no and that that sense of
injustice of why does everyone get to be
okay but me like that's yeah this this
thing this thing went heavy on I was
gonna say on the fields but that like
implies like all tears and lions you
know there was there was some there's
some touching moments but like this
thing went hard on the emotions it went
with and hey got some really good stuff
out of it it the the season overall
really picks up steam as it goes there's
a lot of momentum in this season the the
front end is it's it's good it's solid
um on Tara was okay
you know the I don't know there was
something about the look and Gina
Davis's vocal performance neither of
which are bad but there was like
something throwing me off a little bit
on both fronts I mean I can't really
quantify it it was fine though it didn't
it by no means right to anything so that
was fine
tongue yeah sure I love that they have I
had that toy so I knew that Chi that's a
deep cut and I loved it um
scorpy is still adorable and still
amazing and awesome God for so much mana
cosplay of Scorpius so freakin bad and
to see oh here's something I wouldn't
have called they you know who knows how
far they commit to this but they
definitely set up this very cute if you
are a shipping type shippable
relationship between Hordak and
entrapped uh I wouldn't call what I kind
of love it and actually I was surprised
they they humanized Hordak a bit and it
worked it didn't annoy me and I didn't
feel that it undercut him as a villain
they may they they did two things that
normally I would say don't do that
you're undercutting your villain one
they established that there's somebody
much worse than him out there horde
Prime and that is a holdover from the
show so I knew that was a possibility
and then to you you get us you humanize
them a bit and get us to sympathize with
them and that usually takes some of the
some of the groundwork out from you know
them being an intimidating villain in
this case it didn't because it gave you
more of an insight into why he's
prepared to do what it is he's going to
do um I do I'll make the comparison
anyway it's not on the same level so
like I'm not comparing the quality of
them as a villains but it's a little bit
how humanizing Thanos made him a better
villain that is also the case here with
Hordak the little bit of humanization we
get with him makes him a more compelling
villain than he otherwise was and he was
working just fine prior to that so that
was cool I did I'm just jumping around
now I did see coming what was going to
end up being the final
for the portal with Angela I saw that
coming by about five minutes or so it
still worked
was still the Scylla like I feel like
she needed a bit more screen time this
season if they were gonna pull that yet
at the same time I don't know where they
could have put that in given the pace of
the story that this season is telling
but it still worked I just feel like if
we couldn't if we could have gotten a
little more time with her it might have
worked a touch better but it's still
solid by all means and the action is fun
Edoras good I I'm really I'm feeling her
pain a lot to this season in her
frustration at trying to figure out
what's going on and realizing she's
she's from the other side of this portal
but doesn't know what that means if it
means anything if she's ever gonna get
to find out probably got to Z Madame
razz again haven't seen her since the
first season I was wondering when she
was gonna turn backed up and that was
that was a fun bit I learned a little
bit about Mara finally they've been
teasing that for a while now Oh tiny
detail that I that I really loved
so haunt Aras sort of little henchmen
that catcher takes over one of them's
lizard
looking character that is just short
squat muscular has four arms and has no
discernible like sexual sexual
characteristics but everybody
immediately refers to this character is
she they all immediately identify her as
a female and nobody ever like even hints
that they have a hard time telling I
just I don't know why I really kind of
love that that this is a character with
zero you know sexual identity to
identify herbal features at least to you
know like humans eyes but everybody just
looks at this lizard and go oh yeah
that's a girl we know that and like cool
I just I just kind of like that and this
this show just makes me happy
I mean that's what the show is this this
show is right now is my is my animated
happy place I I can go to the show and I
could re watch the show and it just
makes me feel nice I I love the
characters I love the story progression
I love the look the design I love the
humor I love the emotional impact when
it decides to go for that
I love the heck out of this show how
long am I gonna have to wait for more
but however long it is too long sheera
season three you seen it would you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it a bunch of stuff to do
besides they got a patreon if you want
to help me cover my bills I've also got
other things down there links to a
podcast in a book and my peel box is
down there all sorts of things click on
them they'll take you places you also
don't have to because at the end of the
day folks you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]